ist diese mpk nur ein taktisches manöver
tatsächlich von csu von cdu um bei den
beschlüssen eben doch wieder irgendwie
am tisch zu sitzen
aber das finde ich sogar okay wenn die
also wenn jeder das interesse hat mit
einem tisch zu mir tut es einfach leid
ich jetzt deutlich und verloren haben
und wir praktisch da gemacht wird also
wir hätten auf landesebene längst nicht
länger sagen müssen und wird noch den
karneval so wie jetzt waren wir so nicht
durchführen können
wir auch die weihnachtsmärkte dies sind
selbstverständlich in der jetzigen
situation sind den ich wirklich bahn war
nicht durchführbar da muss man ehrlich
sein wir werden in wenigen wochen in
drei wochen oder vier wochen werden wir
eine so vater haben dass wir aus die
intensivstationen komplett überlastet
haben wir werden die patienten von einer
stadt zur nächsten pflegen müssen das
sind ja die leute die jetzt schon
infiziert sind das kennen wir ja gar
nicht mehr abgewendet und dabei versteht
immer nicht also da werden der junge
leute eng miteinander sind also die da
der natur das doch nicht aber die
infizieren sich und die infizierten in
ihren familien ältere und dort leute die
nicht so gut geschützt sind das heißt
wir haben andere werte die derzeit läuft
und da müssen wir sofort handeln und das
muss grundsätzlich seien also diese
woche noch vor der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz so viel
machen auf landesebene wie möglich und
bei der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
müssen wir schauen dass niemand versucht
zu glänzen wie wichtig und wie gut er
ist sondern müssen ganz drastische
beschlüsse fassen für die menschen wir
haben jetzt eine tragödie die sich vor
unseren augen abspielt rodriguez zu
weihnachten rkr lauterbach
werden also eine trial ich nicht machen
aber wir werden ein anderes system haben
wir werden die situation haben wo wir
viele ein dass er die eigentlich gemacht
werden müssten nicht machen wie die
betten benötigen also das haben wir in
dieser form noch nicht gab es so eine
situation
und wir können auch nicht mehr jeden in
dem bundesland behandeln wo er sich
infiziert hat wird das heißt wir müssen
von bundesland zu bundesland heute dann
auslegen ich bin mit vielen kliniken im
direkten kontaktes wird derzeit
vorbereitet
man im prinzip über ein system sozusagen
der hubschrauber verlegung noch
irgendwie versucht die welt so zu
brechen aber wir müssen uns schnellstens
zu beschlüssen kommen das sind
drastische warnungen wo ich mich ein
bisschen gefragt habe helge braun
wolfgang kubicki wenn das alles
tatsächlich so schlimm ist und der rk ii
chef lothar wieler sagt es ist fünf nach
zwölf das bedeutet ja an uns an uns
zuschauer an uns bürger an uns wähler
gerichtet ist sowieso schon zu spät im
grunde also wenns so dramatisch ist
warum dauert das dann bis zu der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz eigentlich
solange also warum wartet man dann noch
mal eine woche kündigt das in ruhe an
wenn es doch so dramatisch ist wenn es
fünf nach zwölf ist nah die
ministerpräsidenten der b-seite bayerns
sachsens rufen seit drei wochen nach
einer ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und
es war den ampel gesprächen geschuldet
dass sie jetzt als stattfindet aber wir
sollten das jetzt nicht weiter vertieft
noch das ist schon ziemlich
dramatisch deswegen operationen
verschoben werden müssen weil sie nicht
aus dem knick gekommen sind in der ampel
das ist ja der vorwurf von herrn braun
herr kubicki hat lauterbach sie sind
nicht aus dem knick gekommen war
wichtiger
das ist ja vor aber das ist aber das
geht mir langsam wirklich ein bisschen
weit und dann also herr brauchen muss
man ein bisschen auch unseren
redlichkeit erinnert werden nicht diese
bundesregierung ist im abend sie kann
handeln sie hätten mit bayern und
sachsen und wie man auch immer noch
gemeinsam gespräche führen können ich
bin klein gesprächen beteiligt die auch
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz und ebenen
stattfinden aber ich kann ihnen sagen
dass die landesregierung
schleswig-holstein reagiert hat es gibt
eine neue verordnung bei uns in reaktion
auf die steigenden zahlen niemand wäre
daran gehindert gewesen das zu tun dass
sich bayern und sachsen jetzt hinter
ihren hohen zahlen verstecken und sagen
der bund ist daran schuld dass wir uns
die zahlen explodieren kann ich nur
sagen schuld ist die tatsache dass ich
ja so wenig impfen man muss man sich
fragen wie kriegen sie ein größeres
potenzial leben und nicht ja das haben
sie einander ganz schön versammeln
versammelt haben sie das boostern nehmen
aber dadurch sendet und da darf ich sie
voll mit noch mal was sagen weil langsam
langsam kommen wir eine komische
gemengelagen brauchen auch sie sie
müssen an ihre verantwortung erinnert
werden wenn sie jetzt erklären dass
impfungen nichts nützen das lot die
games sind auch wieder alle zu hause
bleiben müssen in kleine veranstaltung
gehen können haben wir ein riesenproblem
in der kommunikation ja aber jetzt
entschuldigen
meine tätigkeiten sind nämlich nicht
erinnern doch offen einig müssen sie
nicht sondern und ich habe nicht gesagt
dass impfung nichts nützen das ist doch
alles das hat nun völlig außerhalb
dessen was ich den ganzen tag sein
impfung ist das a und o maus der
pandemie zu kommen aber jetzt müssen sie
wissen dass bei den steigenden zahlen
wenn wir in zwei drei wochen volle
intensivstationen haben wir jetzt eine
verstärkte impfkampagne und dieses
problem alleine nicht mehr löst und
deshalb müssen wir sagen welche
maßnahmen wir zusätzlich in den ländern
machen wollen und es ist einfach ein
faktum dass wir seit drei wochen
eigentlich eine
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz brauchen
wir am 26 stück gemacht übrigens
bekommen die infektion aber gehen kannst
sie weiß sogar um 37 solange also kein
kubicki hat audi ag waren zu langsam und
vorher war er branche langsam und der
blume waren zu lang 100 litern das geht
voll auf ihre kappe nehmen